MY MAN IN THE MIDDLE.
ACTUALLY, LET ME DO IT RIGHT.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY, THIS IS
A NEW YEAR, A HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
YOU GUYS, WELCOME EVERYBODY WHO
HAS COME TO THE SHOW.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY.
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN I LIKE TO
CALL MICHAEL BOLAN, NEXT TO
HIM, THE MAN WE LIKE TO CALL
AROUND HERE PRODUCER RYAN, HOW
ARE WE DOING?
ARE WE GOOD?
>> WE ARE GOOD, THINGS ARE GOOD.
NEW YEAR, SAME ENERGY, GOT MY
LUCKY VETTING SHIRT ON
>> OKAY. RYAN.
NOW, RYAN HAS BEEN QUIET.
USUALLY RYAN IS A TROOPER, BUT
HE HAS BEEN QUIET, BEFORE THE
SHOW.
HOW ARE WE FEELING TODAY?
ARE WE GOING TO WIN?
>> I AM FEELING CONFIDENT, I
THOUGHT IN THE NEW YEAR I WAS
GOOD TO BE THE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE FROM YOU, CRAIG.
[ LAUGHTER ] I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO WORK TOWARD THAT PICKS MAC
PRO, I'M GIVING YOU YOUR KUDOS.
YOU ARE A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
MIKE IT IS NOT UP TO ME TO
DECIDE IF YOU ARE A MAN, IT IS
UP TO THE PEOPLE, YOU KNOW WHAT
I AM SAYING?
>> YEAH, YEAH PICKS THEM UP
WELL, IF YOU GUYS KNOW WHY WE
ARE HERE, THE PEOPLE KNOW WHY
WE ARE HERE, IT IS TIME TO COOK
UP ANOTHER NBA FIVE LEG HARLEY,
DROP YOUR BEST BETS FOR TONIGHT
IN THE CHAT, DROP THEM IN THE
CHAT, USE THE CHAT FINGERS.
WE ARE TALKING TNT GAMES ONLY
TODAY.
WE ARE WHAT TALKING ABOUT TNT
ONLY GAMES.
RYAN, YOU HAVE BEEN QUIET. IS
THAT GOING TO CHANGE?
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE TALKING?
>> IT IS GOING TO CHANGE FOR
JUST A REMINDER, THE TWO GAMES
THAT ARE ON TNT OUR BOSTON
CELTICS AND DALLAS MAVERICKS,
AND WE HAVE IT RIGHT UP THERE,
THE LOS ANGELES CLIPPERS AND
THE DENVER NUGGETS.
SO, LET'S DO IT PICKS THEM UP
LET ME JUST SAY, TO START 2023,
THIS IS ABOUT A GOOD IS A
DOUBLEHEADER AS YOU CAN HAVE ON
TNT.
A LOT OF STAR POWER TONIGHT.
SO, WE JUST HAVE TO GET THE
RIGHT PICS SO WE CAN START THE
YEAR OFF RIGHT.
>> YES, DEFINITELY WE NEED TO
START THE YEAR OFF RIGHT.
-- DROPPED THREE, BUT I AM ONLY
GOING TO ACCEPT ONE OF THEM.
HE SAID TAKE HIM OVER 31 1/2
POINTS, LUKA OVER 34, GINA
BROWN OVER  27.
THAT'S A LOT OF POINTS.
>> AND I GUESS WHICH ONE YOU
LIKE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO, YOU SAID BEFORE THE SHOW
I AM QUIET.
I TELL YOU EXACTLY WHY I AM
QUIET.
THIS GUY ALWAYS OUTS ME FOR THE
PICKS I HAVE FOR THE SHOW
PICKED UP IN WHAT I AM GOING TO
SAY PICKS PAYMENT  HE LIKES
JASON TATUM OVER 30 POINTS.
THAT'S WHAT HE LIKES.
[ LAUGHTER ] IMMIGRATE, TALK TO
US, WHY DO YOU LIKE IT DO?
TALK TO US.
HE SAID SOMETHING BEFORE THE
SHOW THAT WAS INTERESTING.
RECALLING THE SAY WHAT?
>> A JASON TATUM LEGACY CAMBRIC
FOR MOST PEOPLE THAT MEANS 40+
POINTS.
FOR ME IT IS TAKING THE POINT
BELOW WHAT HIS POINT TOTAL
ACTUALLY IS.
WE ARE TEASING THIS OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ] THIS SOUNDS LIKE A
NEW YEAR'S RESOLUTION LIKE YOU
ARE CRYING OUT FOR HELP.
[ LAUGHTER ] MISSES YOUR CRY
FOR HELP.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE TOO OLD
ANYMORE, YOU JUST WANT TO WIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I LIKE THIS BOOK ARE TWO
RECENT PICKY COMING OFF A BAD
GAME, THE MAVERICKS DON'T PLAY
ANY DEFENSE TO HAVE TWO OF OUR
PRODUCERS JUMPING INTO MY EAR
TO SAY THEY LOVE JASON TATUM
TONIGHT.
SO, I FEEL LIKE THAT IS A LEFT
LOVE FOR JASON TATUM FOR ME.
>> SO WAIT.
I DID NOT KNOW THAT -- --
>> THEY DON'T PLAY ANY DEFENSE.
THOSE WERE THREE REASONS.
IT'S BEEN ABOUT, THE SUPPORTERS
PICKED LIKE OKAY, OKAY.
I'M GOING TO LEAVE IT ALONE.
GOOD VIBES, GOOD RIDES.
[ LAUGHTER ] OKAY, JASON TATUM
30 POINTS.
I DON'T DISLIKE IT HE'S BEEN
BAWLING THIS YEAR.
AND IF YOU HAVE TO TAKE ON IT
PICKS I AGREE, I WATCHED THE
LAST GAME BECAUSE I HAD MONEY
ON IT, HE DID PLAY PRETTY BAD.
I WILL SAY, THOUGH, JAELYN
BROWN HAS PICKED UP A LOT OF
SLACK ON HIS BACK GAMES AND I
SEE A PICK IN HERE, JAELYN
BROWN OVER THREE THREES, HE HAS
GOT A LOT OF VOLUME THAT HE
SHOOTS.
BUT LIKE BRIAN SAID, I THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE A HIGH-
SCORING GAME.
EITHER WAY, IF THAT IS ONE OF
THE FIRST PICKS I'M OKAY PICKS
PAYMENT WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU, LIKE I AM OKAY ADDING
IF WE WANT TO ADD A JASON TATUM
IN HERE.
BY THE WAY, THE OTHER NOTE WITH
JASON TATUM IS THAT HE IS GOING
TO SCORE 80 TONIGHT, WE
UNFORTUNATELY CANNOT BET ON
THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT IS FUNNY PICKS PAYMENT
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO GET ENOUGH OF VALUE, WE CAN
ONLY GO UP TO 40.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE
NUMBER IS TO SCORE 80 POINTS,
THAT WOULD BE PRETTY
INTERESTING PICKS BE MET YES.
ALL RIGHT, JAELYN BROWN'S
NUMBER IS AT 2 1/2.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO HERE?
WHEN SOMEBODY GIVES US AN OVER
WE JUST KNOCK IT DOWN A CARD.
WE JUST DROP IT DOWN A LITTLE
BIT -350, THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO
START, THERE WE GO.
I LIKE IT.
I THINK WE ARE AT A GOOD PLACE
TO START.
WE ARE IN A GOOD SPOT THE WAY
IT'S LOOKING, THE CELTICS ARE
GOING TO WIN THIS GAME.
>> WE WILL SEE.
WE WILL SEE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY, I SEE WAYNE 60 SAYING
-- OVER 53 1/2.
I HAVE A BEEF WITH THIS AND I
KNOW RYAN WILL SAY THE SAME
THING BASICALLY THAT I AM.
I CANNOT BET ANYTHING ON KUWAI
LEONARD, BECAUSE SOME DAYS HE
PLACED 29 MINUTES, SOME DAYS HE
PLAYS 60 MINUTES.
SOME DAYS HE JUST IS NOT AN
INJURY REPORT AND DOES NOT
PLAY.
I THINK IT IS TOO RANDOM.
I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE A
REALLY TIGHT GAME.
I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN GO WITH
KUWAI LEONARD PICKS HE IS  --
THE LAST TIME WE BET HE
SCORED 15. [ LAUGHTER ]; THE
ENERGY, BRIAN.
HE BRINGING TO TALK DANCES TO
THE SHOW PICKS PAYMENT THERE
YOU GO, I WAS ACCUSED OF BEING
TOO QUIET.
I WAS NOT READY FOR THAT NEW
SHOW OF THE NEW YEAR.
WE ARE ALL BACK.
[ LAUGHTER ] HE IS BACK.
[ LAUGHTER ] SHOUT OUT TO MY
MAN RYAN.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE HAVE TWO.
WE HAVE TWO LOCKTON. WE ARE
FEELING GOOD ABOUT THIS.
THE AUDIENCE IS FEELING GOOD.
ARE THEY?
DO WE FEEL GOOD?
>> YEAH, WE ARE NOT GETTING ANY
NEGATIVE REACTION, JUST MORE
TAKES, WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
NEED EXACTLY.
WAYNE 60 SAYS JAMAAL MURRAY,
OVER 23 AND HALF POINTS AND
ASSIST. WHY NOT?
>> THAT'S NOT SOMETHING I HATE.
>> YEAH, THIS IS A PROPHET IS
GOING TO OBVIOUSLY BE DRIVEN BY
THE POINT HE HAS TO SCORE. I AM
NOT TOO WORRIED ABOUT HIM
GETTING TO 15 OR 16, MAYBE EVEN
20.
BUT I DO WORRY THAT IF KAWHI OR
PAUL GEORGE, IF HE IS IN OR
OUT, IF YOU CAN, THEY HAVE GOOD
WING DEFENDERS THAT MIGHT MAKE
THIS A LITTLE BIT TOUGH.
>> WE CAN GO TO IT.
YEAH, LET'S GO TO IT, WE ARE
GETTING SOME TAKES, BUT WE CAN
GO BACK AND FORTH.
>> I AM SEEING SOME MORE, KEEP
GOING.
I'M SEEING SOME MORE AND WANT
TO CALL THEM OUT WOULD 20+
POINTS, THAT IS INTERESTING, IN
A GAME THAT FEATURES A LOT OF
POINTS.
BECAUSE 37, SHOUT OUT BK,
STEPHEN ADAMS OVER TO ASSIST.
THAT IS NOT IN THE TNT GAME,
BUT I LIKE THAT AND I THINK I
WILL DABBLE IN THE OTHER
PARLAYS THAT I MAKE TONIGHT.
BUT SHOUT OUT TO BK, GLAD HE'S
HERE PICKS -- HOW CAN RYAN BE
BACK, HE NEVER LEFT?
I TOTALLY AGREE.
[ LAUGHTER ] ALSO, DOMINIC CRUZ
MAC IS IN AND SAYS GRANT
WILLIAMS OVER REBOUNDS.
>> OKAY, I HAVE A TAKE ON THIS.
I BET ON GRANT WILLIAMS, EITHER
LAST NIGHT OR WHENEVER THEY
PLAYED THE THUNDER.
I THINK IT WAS TWO NIGHTS AGO,
MAYBE.
SALT.
>> HE PLAYED REALLY BAD PICKS
BE McKEE WAS ATROCIOUS.
ATROCIOUS PICS MET THE OTHER
THING ABOUT GRANT WILLIAMS, I
THINK HE IS A SOLID PLAYER.
HE ALSO IS JUST LIKE, HIS
MINUTES ARE NOT VERY RELIABLE,
SO YOU NEED THEM TO GET THIS IN
A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME, WHICH
AT SO MUCH PRESSURE, LIKE WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ROTATION
PLAYERS IT IS KIND OF A TOSSUP,
BUT I DON'T HATE THE IDEA OF
THE PLAY, BUT IF RYAN SAYS HE
IS SOLD I WILL NOT TRY TO HAVE
THAT FIVE I AGREE, THAT IS
RYAN'S TEAM.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> YEAH.
I ALSO LIKE AM OF THE OPINION
THAT WE SHOULDN'T GO TOO CELTIC-
HEAVY.
I THINK WE HAVE GOT THE TATUM
AND BROWN AND I FEEL PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT THAT.
I FEEL LIKE IT WOULD BE WRONG
TO NOT INCLUDE LUKA IN SOME
SORT OF WAY AND IS PARTLY PICK
ABSOLUTELY.
>> YEAH, LUKA'S POINTS I THINK
IT IS CLOSE TO EVEN MONEY TO
SCORE AND EVEN 30.
I WAS LOOKING AT IT.
BUT HE HAS BEEN GETTING, I
THINK THEY WENT ON A RUN WHERE
HE HAD OVER 35 AND MIKE EVAN-
STRAIGHT GAMES.
DOES NOT TOTALLY SCARE ME, BUT
THAT GUY DOES IT ALL, YOU KNOW?
HE CAN PASS AND REBOUND.
SO, IF WE WANT TO GET LUKA IN
THERE I THINK THERE ARE WAYS TO
DO IT.
>> WAYNE SAYS LUKA OVER EIGHT
AND HALF ASSIST .
>> I LIKE THAT TOO.
>> SOMEBODY DROP IN A TRIPLE-
DOUBLE.
SO, I LIKE THE SIX.
>> AND HIS ASSIST OUR AT 8 1/2?
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT?
EIGHT ASSIST?  I THINK WE CAN
DO EIGHT.
>> YEAH.
EIGHT OR SIX.
THAT PUTS US AT 221 PICKS THEM
UP THAT'S NOT BAD AT ALL PICKS
PAYMENT YET, THEN WE ARE TWO
AWAY FROM IT YEAH, FROM VICTORY.
, WE COULD SAY THAT PICKS ME
BACK I WILL SAY WE GOT SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CHRISTIAN
WOULD MAXING
>> I DON'T KNOW, THAT GUY CAN
BALL PICKS PAYMENT JUST 20+ IS
A LOT PICKS PAYMENT 20 IS A LOT
FOR HIM, I DEFINITELY FEEL A
LITTLE MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
THE EIGHT ASSIST, I THINK THAT
WE KEEP HIM.
>> I THINK WE SOUGHT ONE FROM
THOMPSON THAT WE LIKED, HE WAS
SAYING JOKER OVER 12 POINTS.
>> LET'S HEAD OVER.
THIS IS ONE THAT I LOVE NOT
ONLY BECAUSE JOKER IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE PLAYERS, BUT HE IS SO
FUN TO WATCH.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT HIM
REBOUNDING, THAT IS LIKE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS LIKE A LOT
FOR HIM.
PEOPLE HAVE TO MAKE SHOTS.
>> HE IS AT 11 1/2, THAT IS
BEAUTIFUL.
>> I AM SURPRISED YOU ARE NOT
DOING WHAT WE NORMALLY DO.
>> WE COULD TRY TO SEE, LET'S
REMEMBER IT'S AT 467, LET'S SEE
IF WE KNOCK IT DOWN TO 10 WHERE
ARE WE AT?
306.
WE COULD SEE WHERE WE ARE AT
AFTER THE FIFTH LEG, BUT I KIND
OF LIKE IT AT OVER 11 AND HAVE
PICKET THINK WE HAVE TO DO ONE
REGULAR OVER UNDER TO GET THIS
PICKS PAYMENT THIS SHOULD BE
THE ONE?
>> WELL, IT DEPENDS.
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
WE CAN ALWAYS GO BACK TO THIS
AND SEE WHERE WE ARE AT, BUT I
WOULD NOT MIND IF WE HAVE TO DO
IT I WOULDN'T MIND PICKS THEM
UP I HAVE A QUESTION.
IF YOU THINK HE IS GOING TO GO
OVER 11 1/2, WHAT IS THE 12+?
>> YOU, WHAT IS THE 12+?
>> OH, IT IS WITH THE 11 1/2
WOULD HAVE BEEN.
SAME THING PICKS PAYMENT ALL
RIGHT, I SEE A REALLY GOOD IN
YOUR, PHILIP MARQUEZ, SHUT UP
TO YOU.
DEREK WHITE OVER THREE ASSIST,
-150, TWO ASSISTS -345, THE
LAST FIVE GAMES HE PUT IT IN
HERE, 6-3-4-3-5 PICKS PAYMENT
SO, WE ARE TAKING THREE?
>> IT FEELS LIKE THAT IS GOOD
NUMBER, I KNOW WE HAVE THREE
PICKS FROM THAT  CELTICS PICKS
PAYMENT THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THAT AND OBVIOUSLY LIKE WE
ONLY HAVE TWO GAMES.
THAT IS A HANDICAP.
IT'S ONLY TWO GAMES.
IF WE ARE HEAVY ON ONE IT WOULD
BE KIND OF FUN TO JUSTÃMIGHT
NOT HAVE TO SWEAT
>> THAT WOULD BE KIND OF FUN.
>> WE ARE JUST PRAYING FOR
MIXES REPEATEDLY FROM THE
CLIPPERS, WHICH THEY CAN DO.
>> WE TOOK 10+ REBOUNDS. ALL
RIGHT, HERE IS MY TAKE ON TRYING
TO GET THIS GOING A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT IF WE TAKE -- OVER 11 1/2
REBOUNDS AND WE TEASE LUKA DOWN
TO SIX.
>> THAT FEELS LIKE A GOOD PLAY.
WE HAVE TO ASK WHAT THEY THINK
ABOUT THE PARLAY ANYWAY.
>> THAT IS MY SUGGESTION.
WE KEEP TATUM 30+, WE KEEP
JAYLEN BROWN 2+3 COMMUNITY
KEEP DEREK WHITE OVER 2 1/2
ASSIST, THEN WE CHANGE JOKIC
FROM 10+ REBOUNDS TWO OVER 11
1/2  HIM AND HE'S LUKA DOWN TO
6+ ASSISTS . SO SHOUT OUT AT ME
FOR NOT ONE TIME MESSING UP
JOKIC 'S LAST NAME.
HE'S BEEN HAUNTING ME ON THIS
SHOW.
McKAY, I HAVE A QUESTION,
THOUGH.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> WHY ARE WE DROPPING DOWN
LUKA ASSISTANT NUMBERS?
WHAT IS THE REASONING?
LIKE I KNOW YOU ARE A MATH GUY,
I KNOW YOU LIKE TO MAKE THINGS
MAKE SENSE. SO, WHAT IS THE
REASONING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT WAS
SARCASM.
I AM NOT A MATH GUY.
I AM VERY ANTI-MATH.
I HATE IT.
[ LAUGHTER ] I THINK IT IS MORE
LIKELY, WHILE JAELYN BROWN THAT
IS THE PLAY WE HAVE A HERE, WE
PUT THAT TO THE SIDE.
I JUST REALLY THINK JASON TATUM
GOES OFF TONIGHT, AND THE ONE
THING THAT IS CLOSEST TO THE
ACTUAL LINE THAT WE HAVE IS
DONCIC, WE HAVE AN 8+ AND HIS
LINE IS AT 8 1/2.
SO, I THINK WE TEASE THAT DOWN,
THE NUMBERING WON'T BE CRAZY.
>> SO, YOU ARE TRYING TO BE A
THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE, YOU ARE
TRYING TO BE THE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE
>> ONCE YOU LOOK, THEY ARE NOT
REALLY LIKING THE IDEA PICKS
PAYMENT LOOK AT THE COMMENTS.
>> I DO THINK THAT THE COMMENT
ABOUT THE EIGHT IS SPOT ON.
TO ME, LUKA MIGHT SCORE 50, BUT
IN THE END THAT HE DOESN'T, A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
CONTRIBUTE.
I KEEP SAYING, WE THINK IT IS
GOING TO BE HIGH-SCORING.
I THINK HE GETS TO THAT EIGHT
PRETTY EASILY.
>> IN ORDER FOR THE MAVERICKS
TO COMPETE IN THIS GAME, I
THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO HELP LUKA OUT ON THE OFFENSE
OF AND.
HE KNOWS THAT,  JASON KIDD
KNOWS THAT, THE CELTICS EVEN
KNOW THAT.
SO, I LIKE THIS ASSIST, I AM
WITH HIM, I THINK HE GETS EIGHT
EASY PICKS PAYMENT SO, WHAT DO
WE THINK ABOUT MOVING, WHICH I
ALREADY DID HERE.
SO, THIS IS ME TAKING CONTROL.
WHAT DO WE THINK ABOUT MOVING
JASON TATUM DOWN TO 25+ POINTS?
PAYMENT THAT LEAVES US AT +416?
>> THAT IS WITHOUT ME ADJUSTING
I KNOW WE HAVE JAELYN BROWN 2+
MADE THREE, DONCIC 8+ ASSIST ,
THAT IS WHAT THE CHAT LIKES
THEY SAY LEAVE THAT ALONE.
DEREK WHITE OVER 2 1/2 ASSIST,
JAYSON TATUM 25+ POINTS, THEN
JOKIC WITH 10+ REBOUNDS, THEN
MOVING DOWN  JAYSON TATUM TO
25, I WOULD SAY MOVE JOKIC UP
TO 12+ REBOUNDS PICKS PAYMENT
LET'S SEE WHAT IT DOES PICKS
PAYMENT I LIKE  THAT.
BUT, WHERE IS THIS COMING FROM?
IS THIS YOU ARE IS IS THE
PEOPLE?
>> I AM JUST TAKING WHAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN ME, THEN
TEASING IT DOWN PICKS PAYMENT
YOU ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT INTO
RYAN'S PARLAY?
>> NO, DOLPHIN IN THE CONTROL
ROOM CHANGED THE CHAT PARLAY TO
RYAN'S PARLAY, BASICALLY WHAT
HE'S TRYING TO DO HERE, THAT
WILL HELP PICK THESE PICKS, YOU
ARE SITTING HERE TO MANIPULATE
THE NUMBER AND MANIPULATE THE
PICKS , NOW WE HAVE 416, WHEN
YOU, THE GUY WHO DOES NOT WANT
TO THAT +600, THE FIVE YOU LIKE
PARLAY DOESN'T GO UNDER 600 A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO PICKS BUT
WHERE IS THE PROPAGANDA HERE
COMING FROM?
WHERE IS THIS SLANDER COMING
FROM?
I WILL SUE YOU FOR LIBEL AFTER
THIS PICKS HE SAID THAT.
>> RYAN, I FEEL LIKE I AM
ALWAYS THE MIDDLE PERSON IN
THIS.
[ LAUGHTER ], YOU OR I CAN TALK
IT TODAY PICKS MAKE YOU ARE,
SEE?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
FIRST IT'S QUIET NOW AND OUT-OF-
POCKET, NOTHING IS OUT-OF-
POCKET.
THE CHAT IS GIVING ME THE PICKS.
>> I AM ACTUALLY FIRING ON YOU,
BECAUSE -- I TRUST RYAN, AND HE
IS LAUGHING.
I CAN'T TELL IF HE IS BEING FOR
REAL OR NOT.
I THINK HE'S BEING FOR REAL,
THERE'S A LOT OF EXPLANATION
POINTS.
>> A LOT OF LAUGHTER AND MOVIES.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I PREFER TO LOOK AT IT IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
THIS IS WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY.
WHAT I DON'T WANT IS I DON'T
WANT TO COME IN HERE NEXT WEEK
AND THE CHAT GAVE US A PICK AND
I'M SITTING HERE WITH MY FEET
KICKED UP SAYING WE LOST
BECAUSE OF THE CHAT, THAT'S NOT
WHAT I WANT.
I WANT THE CHAT TO BE OVER 31
1/2 POINTS FOR JAYSON TATUM,
AND RYAN TO SIT DOWN TO 25+ AND
WE ALL GET RICH PICKS PAYMENT I
LOVE THAT THE CHAT HAS BECOME A
REALLY OPEN AND HONEST
COMMUNITY, BECAUSE DARIEN 85
WAS IN FAVOR OF YOU, RYAN, BUT
THE INSANE QUOTATIONS, MAN OF
THE PEOPLE PICKS PAYMENT ARE WE
ANNOYING THAT HE CAME BACK HERE
TO SAY LEAVE RYAN ALONE, HE
CAME THROUGH IN THE CLUTCH LAST
WEEK?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING, HE'S
ON YOUR SIDE.
YOU HAVE GOT SOME NUMBERS.
LIKE I SAID, YOU ARE A MAN OF
THE PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE MEANT, BUT
HONESTLY, JOKES ASIDE, I LIKE
WHAT YOU DO HERE.
WE ARE AT +621.
WHAT YOU DID FISTED US UP.
AGAIN, THIS IS WHAT I DO, THE
COMING THE NUMBERS GUY, THE MEN
OF THE PEOPLE, THE NUMBERS GUY.
EVERYTHING.
>> YOU JUST SAID YOU DON'T LIKE
MATH, HOW ARE YOU THE NUMBERS
GUY?
I LIKE IT, I JUST MANIPULATED
THE NUMBERS, LOOK AT THE ODDS
ON THIS AND, IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> OKAY, LET'S GET BACK INTO
THE CHAT, BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
TAKES LIKE RITTER DOES NOT LIKE
DEREK WHITE, HE SAID HE'S NOT
GIVING US A PLAY, HE SHOULD
KNOW WHAT THE SHOW IS ABOUT.
IF WE WANT TO TAKE OUT,  TAKE
IT OUT PICKS PAYMENT TELL HIM,
MB.
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE IT OUT,
GIVE ME SOMETHING THICK
EXACTLY, THAT IS IT.
>> I'M NOT ASKING MUCH.
>> YOU, RICHARD BAYNARD SAYS
JAMAAL MURRAY OVER WHITE.
BUT AGAIN, WHAT SPECIFICALLY?
AGAIN, YOU HAVE READ THE
NUMBERS FOR DEREK WHITE.
WHICH WAS BOWLING, YOU READ THE
NUMBERS THERE PICKS PAYMENT
THERE YOU GO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> COMPENSATING IT'S A BAD
HANDICAP WANT TO TAKE IT OUT, I
THINK WE CAN GET, I REALLY THINK
WE CAN BUY SOME DOWN, BUT IT DO
WHAT YOU DO.
YOU ARE THE ANALYTICS I. NOW I
AM THE NUMBERS GUY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALL RIGHT.
HOW LOW CAN WE BUY DOWN?
IF WE CAN GET DEREK WHITE. HOLD
ON, LET'S LEAVE DEREK WHITE IN
THE PAST AND MOVE ON TO
SOMETHING BETTER.
>> SO, THIS IS MY SUGGESTION,
DO WE WANT SOMETHING FROM THE
LATER CAME, I LIKE GETTING
THROUGH THE EARLY GAME AND ALL
WE HAVE TO DO IS ROOT FOR
JOKIC, WHICH COULD BE FUN.
>> BK JUMPED IN WITH A GOOD
NOTE, HE SAID WE ARE WALKING A
FINE LINE WITH 12 VOTES AGAINST
A TEAM WITH MULTIPLE GOOD
REBOUNDERS.
>> SO, THAT JUST MEANS PICKS
PAYMENT THAT'S THE SAME THING
IS GOING OVER 11 1/2.
>> I GET WHAT YOU ARE SAYING,
BUT WHAT I THINK, THIS IS A
CROSSROADS.
IF WE TAKE SOMETHING THAT IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONTROVERSIAL
AND WITH BETTER ODDS, THEN WE
CAN DROP THEM DOWN TO 10 AND IT
FEELS MORE LOCKED.
THERE'S A LOT THAT PEOPLE
REALLY WANT. THEY REALLY WANT
TO LOOK AT THIS CHRISTIAN WOOD
NUMBER.
I THING IT IS PROBABLY TOO
MUCH, BUT I THINK THERE ARE
PLAYS OUT HERE TO BOOST THIS UP
PICKS MAC MY BOYS SAID BRO,
TAKE MARCUS SMART TWO STEALS
PICKS PAYMENT MARCUS BUT IS NOT
PLAYING TONIGHT, I DON'T THINK
PICKS THEM AGAIN, I THOUGHT IT
WAS FUNNY.
LIKE DO YOU EVEN THAT ON HIM?
MIKE CAN YOU BET ON STEELS?
SERIOUSLY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THAT IS NOT MY EXPERTISE.
WHEN 60 SAID NEXT WEEK I WILL
TELL YOU ABOUT JAMAAL MURRAY.
TELL ME ABOUT HIM NOW.
LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU.
>> YOU JUST WANT TO FOCUS ON
DEREK WHITE PICKS PAYMENT OKAY.
THEN HOLD THE PHONE.
LET'S DO THIS.
>> ANYBODY HOLD ON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO A
PLAY THAT WAS HEARD EARLIER
PICKS OH, I FORGET THE USERNAME
THAT DROPPED IT.
SO, WHEN I SAY THIS, CALL
YOURSELF OUT SO THIS IS NOT
LIKE A RYAN PLAY, THIS IS RYAN
COOKING UP RYAN'S PROBABLY,
THAT'S NOT WHAT IS HAPPENING.
IT IS NOT.
SO, I AM GOING TO TEASE JOKIC
BACK DOWN TO 10 BOARDS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
AND WE GO TO PLAYER COMBOS AND
WE TAKE THOSE EARLIER, JAMAAL
MURRAY, OVER 23 1/2 POINTS AND
ASSISTS.
NOW, WHY CAN'T WE DO THAT?
OH, BECAUSE OKAY PICKS PAYMENT
LET'S LOOK AT HIS POINTS.
>> OKAY.
>> SHOUT OUT WHEN 60, THAT'S
WHO IT WAS, WAYNE 60.
AND WE JUST FOUND OUT THAT WE
ARE NOT ALLOWED BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT HAVE THE PLAYER COMBO IN
THE SAME GAME PROBABLY PICKS 17
1/2 POINTS.
>> IS JAYLEN BROWN NUMBER, I
DON'T NEED TO SURVEY  PURPLE,
LET'S DO WHAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> I'M ALWAYS SITTING OFFICER
YOU CAN THROW WHATEVER YOU
LIKE.
>> I'M COMING HIGH IN ON THE
NEXT PAGE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HERE WE GO.
ALL RIGHT.
HE HAS JUST MADE ME FORGET WHAT
I WAS TALKING ABOUT PICKS
PAYMENT YOU WERE GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT JAYLEN BROWN.
>> OH, TWO ASSISTS.
IS THIS NUMBER REALLY AT TWO
ASSIST?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER SEEN
JAYLEN BROWN ASSIST.
McQUAID, CAN WE ASK WAYNE 60
REALLY QUICK AND HE IS THE
BIGGEST JAMAAL MURRAY GUY I'VE
MET IN MY LIFE.
DO WE LIKE, WHAT DO WE LIKE
BETTER?
JAMAAL MURRAY OVER 17 1/2
POINTS?
OR DO WE LIKE HIS ASSIST AT
OVER 5 1/2?
AND THEN WE HAVE RITTER IN HERE
FOR 15+.
>> 15+ IS LUCKY, THOUGH.
>> YEAH PICKS PAYMENT LET'S SEE
WHAT MY MAN WAYNE SAYS, THEN WE
CAN DEBATE
>> NO, WE CANNOT DO 15+, LOOK
AT THIS.
+322?
>> YEAH, THAT IS BECAUSE WE
ONLY HAVE FOUR PICKLE, IS THAT
THE FIFTH LEG?
>> YEAH, BRING JOKIC BACK UP TO
12.
HE'S GETTING THAT PICKS MAC I
DON'T HATE IT.
I DON'T HATE IT.
I SAY GO LOOK AT IT.
YOU ARE IN THE POCKET PICKS
PAYMENT YOU GET JAMAAL MURRAY
AT 15 POINTS, YOU PUT JOKIC
BACK UP TO 12, WHAT ARE THE
NUMBERS?
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO IT, I JUST
WANT TO SEE.
AS THE NUMBERS OF THE SHOW,
THAT GETS US TO +468.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW ME, I LIKE IT AT LEAST
+500 PICKS PAYMENT THAT'S WHAT
I WAS TALKING ABOUT.
SO, +500.
OKAY.
LET'S START IT WITH 600 PICKS
PAYMENT SO, WHY DON'T WE TALK
MORE ABOUT THE LEGACY GAME WITH
JAYSON TATUM AND PUT HIM BACK
TO 30.
>> OKAY, MB.
OKAY PICKS PAYMENT THAT IS A
LEGACY GAME.
YOU SAID LEGACY GAME OVER 40
POINTS PICKS PAYMENT YES.
>> OKAY, GO AHEAD PICKS MAC IS
JUST GOING TO SAY, GENOCIDE TRY
SOMETHING, DON'T YELL AT ON
THIS LOOKS REALLY GROSS FOR A
SECOND.
BUT IF WE GET JAYSON TATUM BACK
UP TO 30, HE'S AT -800 RIGHT NOW
FOR 25+ PICKS SO, IF I TEASE
JOKIC BACK DOWN TO 10 . NO
YELLING, ALL RIGHT?
>> ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
DO YOUR THING PICKS PAYMENT
HOLD, HOLD.
HOLD THE LINE.
>> WHEN IT COMES BACK UP, IT
HAS TO SAY RYAN'S PARLAY.
[ LAUGHTER ] IS UNBELIEVABLE
PICKS PAYMENT IT CANNOT SAY
THAT CHATS PARLAY, IT HAS TO
SAY RYAN'S PARLAY.
NICOLE PICKS PAYMENT THE WORK
YOU ARE DOING LIKE THIS NEEDS
TO BE YOUR PARLAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WE DID ALL OF THAT.
COULD GO PUT IN THE 12 BOARDS.
LET'S GO.
BUT THE 12 BOARDS, 25 POINTS,
RIGHT?
ARE YOU SAID 30,  MB ?
>> 30 POINTS FOR TATUM, GETTING
THUMBS UP FROM RITTER, BECAME
RIGHT WITH THE 12th FROM THE
SQUAD.
>> HE GETS IT, THAT'S WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING IN THE COMMENTS
PICKS MAC RICHTER JUMPED IN LATE
, THEN STARTED SLANDERING DEREK
WHITE PICKS SO, YOU KNOW, I'M
TAKING HIS TAKES WITH A GRAIN
OF SALT RIGHT NOW.
[ LAUGHTER ] OKAY, WE ARE
GETTING IT BACK.
THAT IS WHAT IS WHEN TO BE
RIGHT HERE PIXMAP KNOW, THIS IS
GOOD. I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS.
LIKE SERIOUSLY.
WE WANT LOCKING THIS IN?
ARE WE CALLING IT?
>> RYAN'S PARLAY.
HE PICKED THANK YOU, CONTROL
ROOM.
THIS IS DEFINITELY RYAN'S
PARLAY PICKS BEEN NECK IT IS
NOT PICKS MAKE IT IS NOT THE
PEOPLE'S, IT IS NOT THE
PEOPLE'S.
>> LISTEN, JUST BECAUSE I AM
THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE DOES NOT
MAKE ME THE PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT HOW THIS GOES.
>> IF YOU WERE A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, YOU WOULD RESPECT THE
PEOPLE'S DECISIONS PICKS
PAYMENT I AM, THE PEOPLE ARE
GIVING US, THESE ARE ALL TAKES
FROM THE CHAT PICKS PAYMENT
THESE ARE YOUR TAKES, YOU ARE
TAKING WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
GIVING YOU, AND INFUSING RYAN
INTO IT.
THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
SOME QUICK FEEDBACK ON THIS,
DANNY MARIE SAYING SHE LIKES
THIS ONE.
SHE SAYING THIS IS MORE
WALKING, THOMPSON SAYS I LIKE
IT, LORI SAYS MARK IT IN, +24
1/2 POINTS.
THAT IS NOT IN THE TNT GAME,
BUT YOU SHOWED UP LATE SO I'M
NOT GOING TO GO OFF.
BUT, THIS FEELS PRETTY GOOD TO
ME.
I LIKE IT.
>> I LIKE IT TOO PICKS PAYMENT
HE THOMPSON SAID RYAN, EMBRACE
YOUR PARLAY, IT IS LAW IN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M GOING TO BE ON WELL
TONIGHT IF WE ARE BRINGING THIS
AS RYAN'S PARLAY.
>> OKAY, WAIT.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
LET ME ALSO SPEAK FROM THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE, THE
LAST TIME WE GAVE RYAN THIS
MUCH POWER WE DID WIN ON
THURSDAY NIGHT.
SO, IT IS LITERALLY ONE DAY
FROM TODAY, WE DID WIN.
-- FOR GRANTED, BUT WE DID WIN.
I LIKE THOSE VIBES.
>> I LIKE THIS.
>> I MEAN, IT SEEMS LOCKING,
THE CHAT IS ROCKING WITH IT.
RYAN IS OBVIOUSLY WALKING WITH
IT, MB HAS IS LUCKY BETTING
SHIRT ON, I KNOW HE'S ROCKING
WITH IT.
I GUESS WE ARE LOCKING THIS ONE
IN.
>> HONESTLY, WE HAVE NOT EVEN
ASKED FOR THUMBS UP OR THUMBS
DOWN.
WE ARE GETTING SO MUCH GOOD
VIBES, I THINK WE HAVE TO LOCK
THIS IN PIXMAP I AGREE.
I WAS GOING TO SAY I WAS NOT
GOING TO CUT YOU OFF, BUT THEY
GAVE US THE THUMBS UP BEFORE WE
COULD EVEN ASK FOR IT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE SAYING THIS IS HOT
AND THEY LIKE IT AND THIS IS
THE ONE WE ARE JUST GOING TO
LOCK IT IN RYAN, WOULD YOU DO
THE HONORS AND READING  YOUR
PARLAY FOR THE PEOPLE?
SOME OF THE PEOPLE'S PARLAY.
BRANDED AS MY, THAT'S OKAY.
WE HAVE JAYSON TATUM, LEGACY
GAME 30+ POINTS, JAYLEN BROWN
2+ THREE-POINTERS MADE, LUKA
DONCIC  2+ ASSISTS, JOKIC 12+
REBOUNDS,  JAMAAL MURRAY 15+
POINTS, FIVE LEGS +676.
I MEAN GUYS, THIS IS AWESOME.
THIS IS GOOD.
>> YOU SAID 576?
>> KNOW, 676 PICKED IT HAS A
FIVE?
I MEANT SIX BIXBY NEXT 676.
>> YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ] I LIKE IT.
DO YOU WANT TO TELL OUR FIVE-
LIKE PARLAY, MAKE SURE YOU HEAD
ON OVER TO FAN DUAL AND OFF
INTO THE TNT THURSDAY NO SWEAT
PARLAY FOR A FREE BET.
IF IT LOSES PICKS PAYMENT WHICH
IT WON'T.
>> THAT IS THAT ADVICE PICKED
DID YOU WRITE MAC THIS?
THAT IS TERRIBLE VIBES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I DID NOT KNOW WHAT WE WERE
GOING TO DO ON THE SHOW,
SOMETIMES WE COME IN AND IT'S
THE GREAT HARLEY OR THE CHAT
PARLAY, THIS IS RYAN'S PARLAY.
XP McKAY, PRODUCER MAX GOT IN
MY EAR AND HE SAID HE WOULD
NEVER WRITE MAC THAT.
--ÃGET THE PARLAY LOSES, FAN
DUAL IS LOOKING YOU GUYS UP KNOW
THAT FIGHTS HERE. LET'S PUT IN
SOME THAT'S MB?
>> LET'S DO IT.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE PICKS PAYMENT
THAT GAVE US A BUNCH OF THUMBS
DOWN, WHICH, TOUGH, BECAUSE HE
DID NOT JUMP IN HERE WITH MANY
TAKES, BUT ALL GOOD.
LUKA  TRIPLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT
PICKS MAC MB, DIDN'T YOU SAY
THAT EARLIER?
I COULD'VE SWORN YOU DID PICKS
PAYMENT YOU, I HAVE NO REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT HE IS NOT GOING
TO PUT UP A TRIPLE-DOUBLE .
EVERY NIGHT HE TAKES THE COURT
HE IS LIABLE TO GIVE YOU 30-15-
10.
IN A GAME THAT WE HAVE SAID A
LOT, FEELS LIKE IT'S GOING TO
BE HIGH-SCORING.
IF I HAVE TO GRADE THIS I WILL
GIVE IT A B+, BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS JUST, HE IS AVERAGING
NEAR A TRIPLE-DOUBLE THE WHOLE
SEASON, WHY WOULD I THAT
AGAINST THAT?
>> AT THAT +390, BY THE WAY.
>> THAT DOES NOT ADD VALUE
EITHER.
I THINK WHEN RUSS WAS GOING ON
HIS TRIPLE-DOUBLE GARAGE THAT
ONE SEASON IT WAS LIKE DOWN TO
+200. I FEEL LIKE THERE IS
DECENT VALUE ON THAT.
>> OH, THE HAITIAN LEVEL CAME
IN, I KNOW YOU ARE IN THE
COMMENTS, BUT THE SAID AT ONE
MORE LAKE.
>> WELL.
IS HE TRYING TO COME IN HERE
AND MAKE THIS HIS PARLAY?
THE LAST TIME WE MOVED IT TO
SIX IT DID NOT GO WELL.
>> BUT, LET ME REMIND THE
PEOPLE THAT I DID IN FACT COME
THROUGH.
COME ON, NOW,  MB.
LET THE PEOPLE KNOW.
>> WE HAVE RITTER JUMPING IN
HERE ON THE GOLF LOCK.
I MEAN WRONG SHOW PICKED THIS
GUY COMES IN AND IS SLANDERING
DEREK WHITE AND GIVING US GOLF
LOCKS, LET'S BE BETTER.
CHRISTIAN WOULD, 26+ POINTS,
HE'S UPSET WE DID NOT TAKE IT.
DO YOU LIKE IT?
>> I THINK IT MIGHT HEAD.
IN A FIVE -LIKE ARE LIKE, I
MIGHT WANT TO BET THAT AS A
SOLO PICKS PAYMENT I WAS GOING
TO SAY THAT.
HECK NO, WE ARE RIGHT HERE.
THAT IS A GOOD THING, WE ARE
FLOWING.
RYAN HAS A PROPAGANDA FOR THE
PERSONAL PARLAY TODAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ON IT, WE LOVE YOU HERE.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW, WE LOVE YOU
HERE, BRO.
WE WILL GIVE YOU YOUR FLOWERS
PICKS MAC CLIENT, WHY DON'T YOU
GRADE THIS ONE?
25 AND HALF POINTS OVER 25 AND
HALF POINTS TONIGHT.
OKAY TNT GAME.
>> WELL, HE'S BEEN ON FIRE AS
OF LATE.
WHO ARE THE JAZZ PLAYING
TONIGHT?
>> YOU HAVE FAN DUAL OPEN.
>> I WAS ON THE CELTICS GAME,
THEY'RE PLAYING THE ROCKETS
BIXBY MIKE I LIKE IT, BECAUSE
WE ARE GOING AWAY FROM THE
LETTERS FOR SOME REASON, I WILL
GIVE IT A B. THE TO THINK ABOUT
THE CHICAGO SCHOOLS FAN IS NOT
ONLY ARE THEY KIND OF POVERTY,
BUT THEY ONLY BEAT TEAMS THAT
ARE GOOD.
WE GAVE AWAY -- FOR NOTHING, WE
DO THAT, WE TEND TO DO THAT
WITH LATE BLOOMING ATHLETES
PIXEL, MORE POWER TO HIM, HE'S
HAVING A GOOD SEASON PICKS MAC
AND I WILL SAY A PICK THAT I
LIKE IT HERE, THAT IS SQUISHED
>> CHRISTIAN WOOD-RELATED. OVI
L ROSE SAYS CHRISTIAN WOOD
POINTS AND REBOUNDS OVER 7 1/2.
THAT I DO LIKE THE CELTICS HAVE
REALLY BEEN STRUGGLING ON THE
BOARD SINCE ROD WILLIAMS IS IN
AND OUT LIKE A REVOLVING DOOR
IN THE STARTING LINEUP SO, I
ACTUALLY DO LIKE THAT A LOT, IF
YOU ARE TRYING TO BET ON
CHRISTIAN WOOD TONIGHT, THAT IS
THE PLAY, OVER THE STRAIGHT 20+
FICKETT IS STRAIGHT MONEY IF
YOU LIKE IT GO FOR IT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO DARIAN AND
ANTHONY, I KNOW DARIAN IS FROM
CHICAGO.
I'M ASSUMING -- IS TOO PICKY
SAYS THE BULLS ARE SO
AGGRAVATING AND YES, THEY ARE.
I CANNOT UNDERSTAND THE ROLLER
COASTER.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT SOME
OTHER TIME.
>> MAYBE WE GET THEM ON AT&T
GAME AND WE WILL HAVE IT PICKS
MAC RUMOR HAS IT THERE WILL BE
AT&T GAME IN FEBRUARY FEATURING
THE BULLS AT HOME. MY CHICAGO
HOME IS ARE DOWN, LET'S ALL
WAKE UP AT THE UNITED CENTER
PICKS PAYMENT IF THEY KEEP
PLAYING BAD THEY WILL FLEX THE
GAME OUT.
SO I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT
PICKS PAYMENT GO KNOW -- THAT'S
LIKE A GOOD TIME FOR ME, THAT'S
A LIKE A GOOD TEMPO TO ME,
LET'S GET OUT OF HERE.
THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY TO BE
MADE.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO BE MADE.
I HOPE YOU, AT HOME, I HOPE YOU
GO WITH HIS PARLAY AND PUT YOUR
VEGAN AND I HOPE YOU WIN.
RYAN?
READ THE PARLAY THAT YOU STOLE
FROM THE PEOPLE ONE MORE TIME.
THE PEOPLE AND I WORKED HAND-IN-
HAND.
THAT IS HOW I GO ABOUT IT.
I WILL SAY THIS, RIGHT NOW ON
THE GRAPHIC WE HAVE THE ODDS
+676.
I AM WATCHING IN FRONT OF MY
FACE JUMPING 2+693, GOOD VIBES.
THE PARLAY IS -- TREND IS MY
12+ REBOUNDS AND JAMAAL MURRAY
15+ POINTS.
+693, THERE WE GO PICKS BUT
THERE IT IS, THEY JUST UPDATED
IT IN THE CONTROLLER, WE
APPRECIATE YOU.
MY MAN AT HEY FOY.
, I'M TAKING YOU THREE FELLOWS
WHEN WOOD DROPS TONIGHT.
>> OKAY, WAIT A SECOND.
I AM MAKING CHRISTIAN WOOD 20+
POINTS TONIGHT, JUST BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T GET IT IN THE PARLAY,
IT'S AVAILABLE FOR EVERYONE TO
SEE IN THE APP AS SOON AS THIS
SHOW IS OVER.
SO, YOU WILL GET YOUR MOMENT,
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THE FIRST
SQUAD WIN OF THIS NEW YEAR, WHY
NOT START WITH THIS?
>> THERE IT IS.
MY MAN MB DOES BIG THINGS FOR
THE APP, IF HE DID NOT KNOW,
NOW YOU KNOW.
TALK TO MY MAN, HE IS THE PLUG,
LET'S GET OUT OF HERE, THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH.
NOT TOO MUCH, BUT JUST A LITTLE
BIT.
JUST RYAN, REALLY, BUT THAT'S
OKAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> LET'S GET OUT OF HERE.
OKAY, MY NAME IS GREG IVEY,
NEXT TO ME THE MAN I CALL MB.
IF YOU NEED ANYTHING, TAPPING
WITH MIKE I, NEXT TO HIM IS THE
MAN WE ALL LOVE , A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, THE PRODUCER.
WE LOVE YOU, WE LIKE REALLY
LOVE YOU, BECAUSE WHEN WE WIN,
IT IS LIKE YOU ARE HELPING US
WIN.
IT IS LIKE YOUR PARLAY, YOU
KNOW.
>> BRO, I KNEW YOU WERE GOING
TO SAY THAT THIS IS AMAZING,
BECAUSE WHATEVER YOU DO, IF YOU
DO IT, IT IS THE MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, IT WILL BE LIKE A
CELEBRATION OR WHATEVER.
>> IT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
[ LAUGHTER ] THE PEOPLE WILL
HAVE TO MAKE THAT DECISION
PICKS MAC WHAT ABOUT THIS, IF
THE PARLAY HITS SINCE REDEEMING
RYAN'S PARLAY, NEXT WEEK IT IS
THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> WHAT DO I HAVE TO DO?
>> YOU ARE TRYING TO MAKE THE
RULES AGAIN, THERE YOU GO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH, MY GOSH.
BACK LET'S GET OUT OF HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ] HEY, WE ARE OUT OF
HERE, THOUGH WITH SOMEBODY
TODAY, EAST.